from one of the vp's wayne mackey and
you know the conversation goes hey i
know we have a meeting with you um
sometime this week i just wanted to get
you prepared for the meeting um
also you have a lot of work ahead of you
and i said a lot of work ahead of me
okay
he goes welcome to the national football
league
i just went nuts i asked him hey are you
punking me you gotta be kidding me you
know i just been grinding for so long at
this and just just it's just an honor
to be able to join the national football
league
maya chaka joins sarah thomas as the
second female nfl official first black
female nfl official and you know the
more that it happens
hopefully we get to the point where it
isn't a today show story miles that
that's the goal it's just it's normal
exactly and look i think that we've seen
across the league now diversity wins i
mean let's look at what bruce arian's
staff was and look at all of the
different faces that were on bruce area
and staff the more we can see that i
think the better off we'll be
absolutely uh so good news for the nfl
but but for all of these things it's hey
somebody's got to be first
and then hopefully it becomes just
something that isn't even discussed it
isn't even noticed it's no big deal it's
just hey best person for the job that's
who it is and we move forward all right
let's move forward with some of these
questions warren
nw on twitter asks doesn't even ask
three words rus
to carolina i assume he's not talking
about the possibility of russell okung
resigning with the panthers or staying
there i assume he's talking about scott
fitter the new gm who came from seattle
working out a deal to get russell wilson
to the panthers and miles here's the
problem the list of four teams that was
provided to the world last week by
russell wilson's agent did not include
the panthers so the panthers need not
apply
yeah that's what i would say to that too
i mean i think russell wilson made it
pretty clear at least his agent made it
pretty clear for him which teams that he
actually would want to go to and even
though carolina i think would certainly
be interested in russell wilson should
russell wilson be interested in them and
they don't have any interests and
russell wilson doesn't want to go there
because he has that no trade clause it
doesn't seem like the chances are very
high
that russell wilson could go to carolina
unfortunately for our friend there
miles i i still hold out
the possibility
that
mark rogers russell wilson's agent did
not supply the full list of teams and
that he's holding a couple back so it
looks like russell capitulated or he you
know he he wasn't as stubborn as just
four teams would suggest that he
relented that he compromised in order to
get the trade so uh you know whether
it's the jets whether it's the panthers
i just wonder whether or not the true
list
isn't ultimately longer than four teams
we'll we'll see if that's the case if
there's even any trade discussions
involving russell wilson and perez 09 is
it more likely that the patriots sign a
new quarterback or draft one
at 15 your thoughts
yes i mean i feel like they need they
need to bring in some sort of veteran
quarterback who can at least start week
one in case they don't have the guy that
they really want available at 15 for
them to be able to choose so i think i'm
not really answering the question
properly you're saying both you're
saying both you're saying i am
yes because i feel like that's the way
that they should do it look from
everything that we've heard about
jarrett stim it doesn't seem like he's
going to be the guy there that cam
newton is a free agent and maybe there's
a possibility that cam newton comes back
but that would then be signing a free
agent quarterback so yeah i think that
they probably should do both i think it
would behoove them to do both and i
guess we'll see if they end up doing
that
both is a fair answer it kind of reminds
me the time that i was at the at the
fast food restaurant in line behind a
guy who i think had been engaged in some
of chris sims favorite activities and
they asked him here to go and he said
yeah but uh but in this case it works it
didn't work there but but it it it does
work here um hey hey you know there's
been some chatter about mac jones and
the patriots i'm not sure mac jones is
gonna be on the board when the patriots
draft at number 15 but uh they got to do
something because
what they did last year
obviously didn't work didn't get into
the playoffs they were still seven and
nine but this year at some point tom
brady's coming back to town as the
quarterback of the buccaneers and he's
bringing gronk and he's bringing the
buccaneers and you better be ready with
someone that can go toe-to-toe with tom
brady because it's probably the only
time you're gonna face him because they
they do this once every four years
although now with the 17th game there's
a chance they would meet more frequently
than that you have to assume this is the
only time the patriots will ever play
tom brady they got to have a quarterback
that they feel good about for that game
all right a red zone out does the
expected flood of cuts mean we'll see
less teams using the franchise tag this
year miles what do you think
well i think it depends on if they're
using it for the first time or whether
they're using it on a player for the
second time because we were talking
about this in the first segment with
somebody like justin simmons as opposed
to
taylor moton right when it's simmons
he's getting the tag for the second time
so it doesn't have anything to do with
the salary cap it's a 20 raise if it's
moton he's getting the franchise tag for
the first time so it only has to do it's
a percentage of what the salary cap is
so
i again i don't know if i'm i don't
think i'm doing a very good job here
mike of actually answering the questions
but i think it depends on where guys are
because if you really want to keep
somebody based on the salary cap is it
could be okay
now uh i don't know if you saw pft live
this morning but i got completely
twisted up on one topic and started into
the other topic so trust me you're doing
better than i was this morning i'll say
this it's apples and oranges because the
stars are still going to get paid
they're not the ones who are going to
get squeezed franchise tag you're going
to apply it if you have a guy that you
want to keep
and you'll just cut somebody else if you
have to to have the cap space available
to keep that guy that you want to have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports